ich glaube wir nehmen oder hallo dann
hier gibt es auch xxl habt ihr eine
bluse bestellt wurde
ja ich mache das tram die leute was geht
ab jetzt willkommen war einmal ein video
der leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut mir auch ich war nämlich jetzt
gerade im urlaub deswegen kam auch
solange kein video mehr aber ich glaube
dieses video seht ihr erst später und
dann kam halt schon wie ein video und
zwar versuche ich mich heute am anfang
will ich mal kurz zu halten es geht mal
wieder um mich und ich habe ihnen das
ganz besonderes überlegt und zwar habe
ich vor heute ein outfit
zusammenzustellen das ganze nicht
zufällig wie wir das gewohnt seid
sondern wirklich nach einem outfit zu
suchen was schön aussehen könnte also
sprich schuhe große t shirts pullover
mütze unterhose und so und das auf das
soll am ende nicht für mich sein sondern
für marie sie ist nämlich hinter der
kamera
ich habe harrison schon mal schuhe
bestellt sie sind allerdings immer noch
nicht da und was ich auch mal kurz sagen
wollte das handy was ich euch schon
vorgestellt hat also das letzte video
hat zu dem thema das war ja eigentlich
nicht das handy was ich bestellt habe
und dazu habe ich auch eine mail
bekommen ich habe nämlich das falsche
handy wie das passiert ist und so weiter
wenn ihr lust habt dann lasst man doch
nach oben da dann mache ich dazu noch
ein video mit dem richtigen handy dann
eventuell war auf jeden fall total dumm
wir fangen jetzt allerdings an und wenn
das ausland fertig da ist wird natürlich
auch probiert ne bin jetzt vor allem mal
gespannt solche auch mit unterhose und
zu machen
so leute ich bin jetzt hier auf der
unfassbar genialen seite mich ist meine
absolute lieblingsstadt geworden und
hier war schon sofort diese ps4 station
die habe ich ja schon zu hause das wird
mir hier noch mal voll geschlagen
gut ich würde sagen soll ich jetzt
anfangen
ich weiß ja nicht was ich dazu bestimmt
nicht so ein ganz normales auto wird
heute mit t-shirts pullover hose und
schuhen und vielleicht nutze meister
womit soll ich anfangen t shirt oder
okay leute wir fangen an hose ok ich
gebe einfach mal eine pose damen so xxxl
krawatte macht wenn man hier hose damen
eingibt kommt xxxl highways oder jeans
hose damen highway
ach so und die kleine challenge daran
ist übrigens sie weiß nicht wie das
aussieht also ich suche mir jetzt
irgendwas hier aus was ich gut finde und
das wird bestellt ich glaube ich habe
eine favoriten ich nehme diese hier
obwohl jedoch nicht doch nicht doch
nicht ich nehme lieber diese hier welche
holen welche größe soll ich nehmen will
für die hose ja solche modell nehmen
oder xxl nehme ich dann okay also ich
nehme jetzt diese weise einfach weil die
noch fünf euro günstiger ist als die
davor und heute schreibt mir auch auf
jeden fall in die kommentare wie er das
findet ob ich eben wie gut eingekauft
habe dann oder schlecht okay ja ich weiß
nicht mal das ist falsch
ich habe ich nun doch die ich nehm doch
die ja ich habe eine hose für elf euro
im warenkorb man jetzt machen wir weiter
mit t-shirt t shirt jetzt muss ich das t
shirt zu finden ja ich weiß ja auch
nicht übertreiben
t shirt ja das habe ich dir auch bezahlt
wenn ihr das video noch nicht gesehen
habt wo sie mir ein outfit
zusammengestellt hat er guckt mal diese
frau die sich so ein bisschen aus wie du
also wenn ihr das video gesehen habt
euch auf jeden fall nach diesem video an
und ich hat die t shirts sind schon hart
hässlich dass hier gefällt mir schon mal
ich kann ja auch zwei t shirts rein weil
dann ist ja im endeffekt egal
am t shirt welche größe ich glaube oder
dann hier gibt's auch xxl ich vertraue
jetzt ganz auf meinem stil
wir nehmen das wir nehmen das t shirt in
ihr könnt sie hier sehen kann man das
schon mal im warenkorb
ich suche aber noch weiter dass ich hier
finde ich das ist schwer zu sagen ich
glaube ich nehme einfach mal so was hier
noch mit da kann man ja nichts mit
falsch machen aber das eventuell in
einer anderen farbe obwohl mir das dass
nämlich auch in das von den lippen
abgelesen
ok also wir haben jetzt schon mal diese
drei sachen im warenkorb und jetzt
brauchen wir da bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt ich habe mir letztens schon mal
schuhe für mich bestellt wir sind noch
nicht da übrigens diese schuhe vor allem
was letztes noch gesagt dass du solche
schuhe cool findest die nämlich welche
größe 39 gibt nur noch gibt nur 8 9 539
da gibt es ja nicht ach so dann nämlich
x 30,5 eben war das haus verkauft und
jetzt
es kann doch gar nicht sein was er da
nehme ich dann nämlich 38,5 die gerät
okay dann muss ich andere nehmen also
das ist wirklich schwieriger als man
denkt solche so wollen die so leuchtend
bunten nein also diese hier sind ja
total hässlich
ich hatte wirklich sofort briten haben
wir echt gut gefallen vielleicht gibt es
ja ähnlich
ähnliche produkte warte ich habe ich
habe welche ich ab welche leute diese
schuhe in größe 935 und in ja die gibt
sie sehen auf dem foto wirklich gut aus
und die ballern war einfach mal in den
warenkorb das heißt wenn wir uns das
ganze anschauen haben wir jetzt schon
mal diese war dass die schule auch die
wird die farbe wir haben schon mal diese
schuhe dann als kombination zu dieser
hose einmal dieses t shirt und diese
bluse
habt ihr eine bluse bestellt cool oder
ja ich mache das trendy so das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt auf jeden fall noch ein
pullover
nein das kann man ja kombinieren das
muss ja nicht sein weißt du kannst du
einmal das t shirt angst und einmal die
bruse ja der sticht mir sofort ins auge
wenn er eine größe also das ist oftmals
gar nicht leicht aber wir haben jetzt
diese beiden policen nebeneinander und
die gefallen wir beide soll ich jetzt
den nehmen oder den ist einfach alles
voll mit king und queen moody's die sind
wohl ziemlich in hier gibt es sogar eine
ganze king and queen familie das ist gar
nicht mal so leicht
ich nehme ich nehme den medienpreis
kalla vor jurorin longsleeve die swatch
ein paar hundert pullover top bluse
slashfilm sitzen hmmm
ok dann nehmen wir ein m und in rot das
wollte ich dann und spaß wir nehmen in
kolberg in grün
warum hast du hier grün sieht gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus aber ich glaube das
passt am besten deswegen kaufen fünf
produkte im warenkorb noch eine kappe
stellen dazu oder eine mütze oder sag
mal irgendwas nur für die für den kopf
oder eine jacke okay war eine kette eine
kette brauchen wir noch dazu dieser kann
dies kostenlos egal nur den versand
bezahlen
so in silber so leute diese kette haben
wir hier genommen so leute diese kette
nehme ich hier in silber ist sogar ein
herz dran
es gibt ja verschiedene silberne kette
mit dem herz die können ja alle anders
aussehen ok und jetzt würde ich noch die
jacke damen weißt du was ich nehme
einfach mal noch so eine jacke dazu
obwohl würde ich so viel geld jetzt
wieder raus hauen
warte mal in m aber die sieht eigentlich
echt was ist das da dran
ich könnte jetzt hier gar nicht sagen ob
das auf dem vorletzen junge oder ein
mädchen ist an welcher steht ja man
könnte auch frauen gut stehen also die
tu ich erstmal noch im warenkorb und
jetzt schauen wir mal hier rein
wir haben jetzt interessiert mich das
geht sogar schätzung geht er jetzt das
ganze outfit ist nur das outfit wir
haben hier sieben produkte drin schuhe
pipapo alles zentral 0 61 euro und 29
euro versand
so leute also wir haben jetzt diese
jacke die kostet 13 euro dann haben wir
die kette gratis dann haben wir diesen
polit dann haben wir diese schuhe dann
haben wir diese bluse sollte ich die
dose raushauen bei comma warte mal ich
glaube dann ist das noch mal ein
bisschen günstiger weil die brauchst du
eh nicht jetzt haben wir noch mal 17
euro gespart
die bluse ist raus und jetzt haben wir
noch dieses shirt für vier euro und
diese hose
also ich finde ich bin echt mit meiner
wahl richtig zufrieden das könnte
richtig alt aussehen und deswegen kaufe
ich den bus hält ich kaufe den ganzen
bundesland sollte ich habe das ganze
jetzt bestellt ich kann mal kurz gucken
erst konnte es sollte alles spätestens
bis zum 21
april da sein ob das stimmt keine ahnung
kann das ganze kommt doch ein bisschen
später an dass sie zum beispiel erst bis
zum ersten fünf das ist aber noch früh
gibt es auch sachen wie die kälte kommt
es bis zum 14 5 also alles ein bisschen
blöd und verspätet oder hier auf das
t-shirt erst bis zum 14 50 ist natürlich
ein bisschen blöd aber ich wollte
einfach sagen damit euch nicht plündert
also das könnte ein bisschen dauern
ich hoffe ich habe nicht wieder so
probleme die mit dem handy
aber ja mal sehen wenn ihr auch noch mal
bock haben auf 100 zufällig bestellen
lassen nach oben da wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich morgen schon wieder und
umschreibt gerne in die kommentare was
hier noch mal gern sehen würde soll ich
noch mal outfit für mich bestellen soll
ich noch dass und das bestellen und
finde kommentare macht mir menge spaß
und es ist noch einmal dieser
spannungsfaktor da folgt auf jeden fall
bei instagram und snap chat um nichts zu
verpassen und wir sehen uns wie gesagt
morgen hat ein frisches toll